for these winners Smiles come easy after
eight years in the opposition Norway's
labor party will now return to governing
the country
we have waited and we have hoped and we
have worked so hard and we can finally
say we did it
as the vote count progressed Monday
evening prime minister
Ernest sulberg had to admit defeat
the voters want another majority to
govern Norway for the next four years
the conservatives work in government is
over for now
foreign
ahead of the vote many said they would
cast their ballot for more climate
action Norway's wealth is largely
attributed to its Rich oil Reserves
for me personally the main issues for
this election is the environment because
it's here it's becoming more and more
important so I think that the tradition
so to take some responsibility
a lot of my friends have the same
topic the big questions for me in this
campaign are the climate what Norway as
a country should be living off
the labor party is likely to form an
alliance with the Socialist left party
and the center party in a left-leaning
government the results show that the
percentage of women in Parliament will
rise to nearly 50 percent for the first
time
soon the five countries in the Nordic
region will all be led by leftist
governments
let's get more on this from our reporter
Chelsea Delaney Chelsea this was a
campaign dominated by climate change
wasn't it
it definitely was and more than that I'd
say it's a it was a referendum on
Norway's oil industry Norway is really a
living Paradox for climate change it's a
country that has a reputation for being
very Progressive it basically is only
selling electric vehicles now it has a
lot of climate credentials but at the
same time it's made all of its money
basically from
um from oil and it's the largest oil
exporter in Western Europe it is a big
exporter of natural gas but it also uh
wants to do more on climate and it's in
this election in particular people were
looking at things like the recent U.N
climate report which said it's a code
red for Humanity they're looking at all
of the natural disasters we've seen in
Europe this year and and they wanted
more from uh from politicians so I think
that's why we've seen the labor party in
particular which has said that they will
address the climate uh the climate
change crisis really jump ahead and they
will get to choose the next government
so how much of a shift can we actually
expect from this new center-left
government
yeah I think it's going to be
um maybe less than some people had been
expecting
um basically what we've heard from the
the labor party is that they want to
address the climate crisis but they're
not yet ready to abandon oil and you
have to keep in mind how important oil
is for Norway it's worth about 20 of
their GDP it employs 10 of uh of their
Workforce so it really is a crucial
driver for the economy so the labor
party has said they're not right yet
ready to stop exploring for natural gas
they're not yet ready to start to stop
pumping but they do want to find some
sort of compromise with these other
parties so I'd say we probably won't see
an into Norway's dependence on wealth on
oil wealth anytime soon but they likely
will have to take some steps to address
this massive cultural shift that's also
happening in Norway now okay so some
change potentially coming Chelsea
donating thanks for staying on top of it
for us